[Music]
and then yeah awesome so thank you all
for coming
I have a lot of content to get through
so we'll get get right started here hang
on one second
[Music]
yeah okay hang on III can fix this
so thanks thanks for coming to my talk
we're going to talk about post-mortem
debugging in notes yes so first a little
bit about the about Graham my name is
Thomas as was said before I I work on a
lot of open source software I work at
elastic where I also work on open source
software specifically with Nokia's
instrumentation and and I tweet on
Twitter as well and I will after this
talk I will tweet out a link to the
slides so if there are some commands
that I'll show that you can't remember
you can just find the slides on on
Twitter I'm also part of the notice
Diagnostics working group where we work
on tools and API is and no core to make
note ajs easier to debug and to diagnose
problems and some of these things is
what i'm gonna be be talking about here
so what is post-mortem debugging anyway
it's about getting rid of bugs right but
let's ask Wikipedia and the computer
says post-mortem debugging debugging of
the program after it has already crashed
that's certainly true but we have
developed a lot of tools to do this and
these tools turns out can also be useful
to sometimes figure out why things might
happen before they happen so we'll also
get into that so some of these tools is
for example lldp and ela note that we'll
talk about today that's also MDB which
people used to use before LOL LDP
the tool to use a note for for
post-mortem debugging we'll look at is
that there's a lot of other things are
chrome dev tools you probably already
know about that you can maybe load you
can load in a heap dump into chrome dev
tools you can connect chrome dev tools
directly as a remote debugger to a
running application you don't want to do
that in production though so let's jump
right into codons I said this word a few
times what is a quorum so sometimes I
find it really useful to figure out if
you want to figure out why something is
called something and what it is to learn
a little bit about the history so for 20
years before we had rotating hard drives
and and and solid-state storage we used
to store our data on on these things
this is a magnetic call plane are you
viewing it from above and you can
imagine there's like several of these
stacked on top of each other inside a
computer in the in the 60s and 70s and
if we zoom into it we'll see some small
magnetic or a ferrite cores that can be
magnetic and they can have a other
clockwise a counterclockwise magnetic
field and depending on that direction
it's either a 1 or 0 so if you if you
run a program on this very old computer
and it doesn't behave like it should
how do you figure out the state of the
computer there's no monitor back then so
what you would do is this is an IBM 1401
mainframe and this is a 1403 printer dot
matrix printer they will print out the
content of all these magnetic cores as
hexadecimal on to the printer and that
would let's see yeah that would look
something like this
and then you really had to like work
through this and figure out okay what's
the state of my program based on the
memory it could be tricky right but
luckily we've come a long way since then
we still have these memory dumps are
these core dumps that's why we call them
core dumps but we do not knowingly have
the memory we also have
processor registers information about
that we have information about the
program counter and and system flights a
lot of other nice information that we
can use and then we store them in oops
we store them in different file formats
so the oldest one it's not really use
that much but the the most popular one
is LF used in Linux BSD systems etc but
if you're using a Mac you'll probably be
using the I'm not sure if it's called
Mac or a Mac or something like that but
but that's the one you use on a Mac and
how does a you get a core how do you get
a core time you all first you have to
tell the operating system that you want
codons and you use this command you
limit it as you see and then the size of
the columns you want to allow to be
generated because obviously when a
program crashes its program is crash
they can't do anything itself so it has
to rely on the operating system to
generate this dump of memory to disk and
the operating system by default doesn't
do this because you will fill up your
heart disk in no time every time I
program crashes so you you have to run
this command and then when you start
note yes you need to tell it to actually
tell the operating system to generate
this file once it crashes because
normally when you have an uncaught
exception and notice it's actually not
crashing it's just exiting with an
unsere exit code so the operating system
thinks everything is fine so you at this
flag abort an uncaught exceptions which
will make it sent this abort signal to
the kernel and you also generate a core
dump on the fly if you have a running
process and you just want to get a
snapshot of the memory and use a decore
on on linux and keep it a give it the
process ID and on mac you'll probably
use this command it's a bit more
complicated
LD be you can also use that on linux but
it it's a it's ways you decode also
generate small KO files so it's better
and here you can just specify the name
of the file you want it to be output to
so now you have a call file how do you
look into it because we could just print
it out on a piece of paper like in the
60s 60s and 70s but we have some tools
now that are super nice that we just
talked about so LDB is the one you'll
probably be using with note yes
the most common a so by the way I
thought for a long time like it stands
for database no you know it stands for
debugger
that's your how smart I am right but so
LDP is it's cross-platform super super
nice you can install it with homebrew or
if you have Xcode already on your system
you all will actually already have it
but if you don't want to install Xcode
or if you maybe want to upgrade to a
newer version other than the one that
ships with Xcode you can use homebrew if
you want to Mac and you can use apt-get
if you're on Linux for example and what
is a so you use have to install lldp
about l-ltp is a general-purpose
debugger it understands any kind of dump
of memory by any c c program or compiled
program right Russ program as well but
doesn't understand JavaScript right so
for it to be able to understand
JavaScript we need to install a plug-in
into LDP and that's called lll node an
ll node is basically telling it telling
lldp where in memory are the different
things related to note yes is as opposed
to the c code that is libuv or v8
because it understands all the libuv and
v8 stuff and the note note c++ code but
it doesn't understand that the hours
with code so this is what what what they
ll notice is about so the way you run
this debugger is you just give it the
path to the binary and this is important
you need both the call file and the
binary of the of the the program that
crashed because when the binary is
compiled and
of information it's actually compiled
into the binary about how the memory
structure looks and stuff like that so
if you just give the core files well LDB
doesn't know how to interpret the core
file that's why you need the binary and
that's why the binary needs to have
these these extra metadata compiled into
it which all binary today like normally
when you compile a binary that's that's
included and it's also included in know
so you need the path to the note binary
in the path to the to the Co file but
and then when you load LD you then need
to load illah note but it's much easier
to just use this shortcut ll node and
we'll set up the plug-in for you
takes the exact same arguments and and
and there we go right so let's talk
about crashes so this is probably the
first time you'll ever encounter a core
dump when you have a crash and normally
when you have a crash you'll just look
at the stack trace and hopefully the
stack trace is sufficient to figure out
what's going on and why you're there and
as we just heard from previously if you
were here for his talk node now ships
with a sink stack traces if you're using
async/await so so the stack traces will
probably be much easier to debug but
maybe you're on a system that that
doesn't run that new version of node or
maybe maybe you you're just a using code
that is not using async/await so you
have this stack trace here that comes
from someone next stick and you're like
okay but how why where did how did it
get there right so we start up our
server with this important code
exception flag that runs and we sent
every quest to it and then we see this
you can see right there in the in the
bottom there it says that it it it
generated a KO file and and on if you if
you did this on a Mac there we go it
will be stored in slash course and then
the court or the the process ID of the
process
first we'll look at this error measure
so cannot read property fine
first of undefined okay okay that tells
something then we look at the line and
we see okay this is a appserver line 16
okay so let's look inside that we can
see line 16 that's actually number four
and this screenshot here cannot access
first and undefined so that's so some
name is undefined and user that named at
first of name somehow it's undefined but
why is it that okay if this was locally
in development we'll just add a console
log statement and we'll be done but if
this is production this might only
happen once every month and we don't
know why
so we if so so we can get a get access
to the core dump of this and this
clicker is really random we can't get
access to the quarter but this name can
see what's going on right so
so I loaded up a quorum here and I'm
running inside Illinois but I did this
beforehand because it takes a little
time to load up is so I didn't want to
bore you with that and if we ride help
we can see a lot of help about which
commands we can run inside ll DB but we
loaded the v8 plug-in right
the ll node ba plugins we could write v8
help and then we get a specific help for
for the node yes related things and we
can see here there is a BT back trace
they'll comment to show us a stack trace
of where the program was when this core
file was generated if you just write BT
like this will actually not get the back
trace from from the ll node will
actually just get the normal back trace
without the plugin so if you scroll up
here to the top of the back trace we can
see like the last thing it did was it
sent there poor signal right but there's
still have some C code here in in node
landing in the bottom there is also some
C code and so v8 and stuff like that but
in the middle you see there's just blank
blank stack frames why they plank
because this is all with the JavaScript
and we can also see that the memory
address here on in the def column the
memory address is very high compared to
the memory address of the seeker because
the JavaScript code of course lives in
another place in memory but we can write
v8 b t then we get the v8 optimized
version of the stack trace and now we
can suddenly see the JavaScript stack
trace here we can see we have a function
called unsaved and it we can see the
memory reference to this of of this
function you can see it took two
arguments the first argument was was
null and the second argument was an
object so let's and if you remember then
the user that they that name that first
the user object was actually came from
the second document so we can just copy
and just copy this memory address and
then we could say v8 inspects and then
that memory address and we can actually
we can actually see here the objects and
it has one property called n ma e so as
somebody spelled name wrong right and we
can even we can even go in and we can
copy that points to another object
memory copy the memory address of that
object and we can inspect that and then
we can see that it contains two
properties first and last as we expect
it with the values at Thomas and Watson
right we can also go up here at the
stack trace we can see here if it was
Fame number six so we can say v8 now
frame select six so now we select frame
number six and we see some what looks
like a simpler code I think at the end
svh sauce list I think it is yeah there
we go now we actually see the source
code how do we how come we see the
source code I mean this is a quarter
right well it's because of course it's
JavaScript and in JavaScript the source
code is in memory it's not compiled
right so we can just use a source code
of our application here so there's a lot
of cool things you can do with this code
um so now we know why the program
crashed
so another problem instead of crashes
can be an unresponsive process the
process hasn't crashed but it's just not
doing anything it's just hanging right
so you could ask yourself what is your
what is your program doing right now and
again code arms can help you so we have
a program like this it just takes an
object and it takes loops over all the
values inside the object then each all
the properties inside the object and
each value it will stringify the value
right
so I ran that I ran that and I generated
a core time from it I'm not gonna do
that now because it takes five minutes
so but I loaded up the column here and
of course to figure out where was stuck
in where it was hanging I just say v8 BT
for back trace and I get the the the the
back trace or the stack trace of what it
was doing and we can see the frame
number one up here is the function
string if I write and so if I say v8 no
frame selects one v8 source list see the
source code here for the function where
it's hanging somewhere so notice that we
just get the the function we don't know
exactly where and the function that we
were stuck but if we look at a little
bit at it at it we can see we're waiting
over some keys and an object and we're
doing that until there's no more keys
right but the way we check if there's no
more keys as we check if key is not or
not not right but unfortunately there's
no more keys is gonna be undefined which
means this isn't just spin forever
because it will never be null be
undefined we just changed from the also
undefined our our infinite loop will go
away
so so an alternative to that would have
been CPU profiling if you do CPU
profiling on a process and ask the CPU
for example 99 times a second what are
you doing what they're doing what
they're doing
UK place it'll get a lot of stack traces
back and you can use those stack traces
to actually see the same thing so CPU
for profiling would have been a really
good alternative to this
so to recap I'm not gonna necessarily go
that deeply into these slides but these
are also just so if you look at the
slide later you can see all the commands
but you either run keiko or lldp to
generate the code up on this running
process and then you you start a little
note with the commands we saw before and
then the years some you can write a
frame select and be a source list and v8
inspect excetera so this is that's a
press very lightly on this clicker here
so there we go
memory leaks that's that's always a fun
one and super super hard to debug right
so so what is what can I memorably be
while suddenly you you get this error
note yes is run out of memory crashed
but and of course then if you set up
your system to your echo file you can
view the Co file but that doesn't really
help us you well you can look into the
memory but actually before we go into
that let's just look at what memory
leaves are so in in note yes it's a
garbage collector language and there's
always be one root node ah and all other
objects in memory will be referred to
from that root and this year when some
when suddenly a one node loses a
connection there's nobody pointing to it
that's not a memory leak that just means
okay nobody's pointing to me and then
the garbage collector can clean it up so
that's not a memory what a memory leak
is is if
if suddenly you have something it could
be an array for example or it just keeps
on growing and growing and growing and
growing and you never clean this up
maybe that's intended maybe you're just
processing a lot of data but it might be
a memory but the problem is you can't
tell it programmatically you can't like
have an algorithm that Caesar this is a
memory because it depends on the program
right so we need humans who understand
the code and what the program is is that
it's supposed to do to inspect this so
we in ll note here and we use another
command we haven't talked about called
find J as objects so it looks through an
entire band looks for all the jobs with
objects in the heap and it lists them
out like this you can see the total size
and the name and it's all listed and we
go all the way to the bottom it's sorted
by with the with the ones that appear
most at the very bottom we can see there
is one called visit an object there that
it appears like 342,000 oh sorry 235,000
like a quarter of a million times in
memory so it's like mmm I know as an
application developer it shouldn't
appear that many times because I this is
supposed to keep track of the active
visitors on the website and we don't
have a quarter of a million active
visitors currently so there's something
wrong here we're somehow not clearing
these up right so we can use the same
command and say we want to just look at
this set here and we see a lot of visit
objects this is all of them a quarter
million on them when we can select one
of them just just take a random one
check this one check the memory address
of that and we use the inspect we saw
before we use the - M here to also see
the map off of the objects in JavaScript
objects had hidden classes and that's
basically their the memory address of
the hidden class we will also see that
so we can see here and we can we can
reference the the memory address of the
hidden class as well and say ok this
that's here let's try to let's try to
inspect that then we actually see the
hidden class in memory so this is one of
those a visit objects right but okay
this is not what we're looking for we're
looking for references to the previous
visit okay so we can also use find refs
and find reps will ya show you all the
references to the visit object in this
case there's only one and it's an array
and it's quite large so unfortunately
right now
ll note is not clever enough to show us
where this array actually exists this
our code so we have to do a little bit
of manual hunting maybe this can be
approved somebody somebody can make a PR
but maybe the process itself can be
improved because it was a little tedious
what I really would like to see is that
what if you could take a core dump and
convert it into a heap snapshot because
if you have a heap snapshot first of all
it's much smaller then you can load it
into chrome dev tools and you can start
to to inspect it and there's much nicer
UI that's a little bit down the road
nobody's working on this yet but it
would be would be a fun project and
alternatively you can trigger a couple
of heap snapshot manually you can
configure your notifications you just
generate heap snapshots when you send it
a signal and then you can do what's
called Kiba keep dump dipping and heaped
up dump diffing is where you you take a
snapshot at one point in time and the
array at this point is certain size then
you wait an hour or ten minutes
depending on how fast your memory grows
you take another heap snapshot and you
can see okay now we different point in
time the array size is larger then you
figure out what's the difference between
these two heap snapshots and then you
say okay this has grown tremendously
this array and then you can find the the
common ancestor like we did before or
even better because this is a heap
snapshots that means you can do it in in
chrome dev tools
and it can point you directly to to the
object that's retaining these references
so how would we go about doing this so
you could just add this function or this
listener to your node application today
it lists on a user to signal so you can
send a user to signal to the process
from outside the process and then it
uses a brand new feature that just
landed in core in version 11 point 13
which allows core itself to write a heap
snapshot it used to be that we had a
third party a NPM package called heap
dump to do this now it spilled into core
and so you sent this you send kill a
sick user to and then the process idea
of the process and that will trigger
this function and then that it will
write it to disk and return this
function here right keep snapshot will
return the name of the path of the file
that's been written to disk and then you
can load it into chrome dev tools
whenever you try to load a heap snapshot
in chrome dev tools one two three four
five so when the left-hand column
you can load as many keeps nap shots as
you as you want just load the file in
zero two two that you're taking at two
different points in time then in there's
a drop-down up in the top I know you can
like we the details here but that's why
I made the big arrows but there's a
drop-down up in the top where you say I
want to make a diff of these two so you
put it into what's called comparison
mode and then there's a column here so
the table just below this drop-down
shows you all the objects it group by
type and then it's a column where you
sort by the Delta count of this diff and
then below that there is all all the
well you should liked the one you're
interested in then below that you see
all the the references to that and we
can see here we found an array here
right it's a little bit you still have
to hunch because sometimes you might see
okay there's two million strings like
yeah okay but maybe that's okay
these drinks all over the place so you
have to use your knowledge of the
application and off the source code to
do this but this is currently probably
the easiest way to do it
so there was a recap slide I'm not going
to go over the details there I think the
final thing I will do is try to speak
Dutch
and I will say thanks
[Applause]
you